- [Voiceover] Alright we have a graph
of y is equal to f of x
and we wanna figure out
what is the limit of f of x
as x approaches negative three.
And if we just look at
x equals negative three,
it's really hard to see
at least based on how this graph looks,
how what f of negative
three is and if anything,
it looks like we have an
asymptotic discontinuity here.
It looks like on the left side
of x equals negative three,
it looks like we are approaching,
I guess you can say infinity
and on the right side,
it looks like we are
approaching infinity as well.
And we can just look at that and say,
What is f of negative 5?
That's four.
F of negative four is
looks like it is around,
I don't know around eight.
F of negative three is off the charts.
F of negative,
if we continued with this trend
and if we were to asymptote
towards this line right over here,
this vertical asymptote,
it looks like as we get closer
and closer to negative three
that the value of the function
at that point is approaching,
is getting closer and closer to infinity,
at least that's what it looks like
from what we can see on this graph
as we approach negative three
from the left hand side.
Let's think about as we
approach negative three
from the right hand side,
so this is f of negative one,
f of negative two,
f of negative 2.5 looks like
it's up here some place,
f of negative 2.9 would be even higher,
f of negative 2.999
looks like it will just
once again approach infinity
so this type of limit in some context
you'd say this limit doesn't exist
doesn't
doesn't exist in the formal sense
so that's one way to think about it.
In some contexts,
you'll hear people say that this limit
since from the left and from the right,
it looks like it's going to infinity.
Sometimes you'll see people say
that it's approaching infinity
and so this is depending
on what type of a class
what type of a context you're in
but in the traditional sense of the limit
or in the technical sense,
there are ways that you can define limits
where this will make a
little bit more sense
but the traditional definition of a limit,
it would be,
you would say that this
limit does not exist.